[Music]
Well I think any cook loves to hear "that'sdelicious"
but it means a lot more when the food is actually horrific.
It's a dead body. It's a lung. Maybe a roadkill rat...
[Music]
I'm Janice Poon
and I'm the food stylist you cometo if you want a grizzly little something for your table.
What have I done?...
Roasted legs;
peking style whole bodies;
edible insects;
tiny organs for dead rats;
edible snails,
ooh space whales...
(raw of course).
Janice can cook up a mean severed head
but she's pretty much a jack-of-all-trades.
Just how many jobs have you had Janice?
First I was an art director in an agency...
then a caterer;
a cookbook author;
a graphic novelist;
a sculptor;
then a miniaturist;
couturier,
and uh writing... didI forget anything?
Now back to the juicy stuff.
Oh I love the reading part of the creative process.
Lay back on the sofa.
I read as much as possible.
I just do a quick sketch to communicate toeverybody the look I'm going for and narrow the field.
The kitchen is really where the sorrowbegins.
That's where everything that you thought was going to work out great...
doesn't...
and that iswhere you really start to think- well now what am I going to do?
You know it's kind of yummy...
Nothing likea little raw hamburger to get you going.
Hang on - did she just eat raw meat?
As a food stylist I get allkinds of requests from actors who have dietary restrictions.
I didn't expect, however, to get one
from a vampire queen who wouldn't eat meat.
What I used was essentially sweet potato.
That doesn'tlook like meat.
Hmm... maybe I need something to make it more gummy.
I'll put a bunch of glutinous flour in.
Well that's a bit yellow for meat isn't it? So I'll put in some beets.
After a couple minutesof the microwave spinning around, what it needs is a little tiny flax of fat.
I use chopped up rice and just plough that stuff in, oil, and that's really going to make it look visceral.
Surely that'snot edible?
It's not just edible... It's delicious.
Any more tips and tricks?
Well, one little fooditem that we have in a lot of horror movies is corn syrup.
Corn syrup with foodcolouring in it to make it look like blood.
Buckets and buckets and buckets of this stuffget used for TV shows and you just, like, pour iton and lick it off.
I would say the duct tape offood styling is oil
because a little slick ofoil is going to make anything look as if it justfreshly cooked or it's just juicy and delicious.
With fake mold if you want it to be edible youhave to use Dutch processed cocoa, which is a black powder,
spirulina powder, icing sugar, and white food colouring.
You can dust them on your food and it'll look just like mold.  Furry but yummy.
Sometimes Iuse toothpaste because it comes in a tube and you just throw it in your bag and that's littleblobs of mold
but people don't like to eat a lotof toothpaste so there you go.
Some of Janice's mostgruesome dishes feature in the TV show Hannibal.
When I looked at the first Hannibal script Ithought - wow these people are crazy.
Mads was themost adventurous.
He was kind of annoyed withme the first day when I didn't serve up reallung, real brain and real liver...
But then I knewhe was going to be an adventurous eater so itall cut loose from there.
Our final scene was to be Bedelia's dining on her own leg.
The leg was the old go-to pork.
It had a marrow bone at thethigh end and a lamb shank at the ankle end.
I felt I had to apologize to Gillian and I said "GillianI'm sorry I made the leg so big.
If I had made it the size of your leg it wouldn't have lookedas impressive."
She did say, "oh that's beautiful", which is what you really want. She didn't say"oh my leg looks good."
[Laughter]
Any final words of wisdom, Janice?
Part of storytelling, of course, is that tension.
Especially with horror where so many of the characters are, psychically, on aknife's edge.
You want your food to be on a knife's edge too.
You want it to teeter.
Is it horrible?
Is itdelicious?
No. It's horrible and delicious.